let's put your newfound knowledge to the
test for this question I want you to
make some updates to the hometown
project if you need the starter files
check out the instructor notes for
instructions on downloading them here we
can see what it looks like right now
we've got two columns text and images
and we've got the weather and sports
course when we resize the page it's
pretty clear that the content is no
longer fitting the browser let's go
ahead and make it responsive first add a
meta viewport to the page and don't
forget to set the initial scale then I
want you to make any adjustments to the
CSS and markup
so that everything displays in a single
column be sure to use relative widths so
that things stretch to fit across any
viewport width and then finally check
your touch targets and make sure that
they're big enough once you've made your
changes test your site across different
viewports try it on phones tablets and
different desktops and when you're done
here's what it should look like notice
to start off with everything's in one
column and when I resize the page the
content reflows to fit the new viewport
and of course my buttons are nice and
big and easy to press